Bizarre behavior is the last of the positive symptoms associated with
schizophrenia. By positive, we do not mean pleasant, but instead we mean the
presence of. So we've seen the presence of delusions, hallucinations,
disorganized speech, and bizarre behavior. In addition, we also have the
negative symptoms. And these can include non-responsiveness, emotional
flatness, immobility or catatonia, which is striking a strange pose. We also
see reduction in speaking. The inability to complete tasks. Sometimes a lack of
motivation. And even diminished cognitive function. We also see that sometimes
people no longer tend or take care of their personal hygiene and they often
have little to no interest in interacting with others.